this will be the second video in
two-part video series on acute renal
failure in this video we will discuss
the clinical features diagnosis and
treatment of a RF in part 1 of this
video we defined acute renal failure
studied etiology and types and also the
rifle criteria of acute renal failure
click here to watch the first part of
this video discussing the clinical
features of acute renal failure and
first we will talk about the pre in
early RF most of the patients of
perennial a RF have a history of poor
fluid intake or a history of fluid loss
in the form of diarrhea vomiting or
blood loss and most of the signs that
are associated with free renal AR F are
consistent with the findings over
dehydrated patient like low blood
pressure
tachycardia feeble pulse reduced
jugular venous pressure a decreased skin
pinched sunken eyes dry mucous membranes
these patients may also have orthostatic
hypotension low urine output is almost a
consistent feature with pre general AR f
renal AR f has different types of
histories depending upon the etiology
which causes AR f a history of previous
sore throat which may indicate nephritic
syndrome due to post streptococcal
glomerular nephritis may present with a
triad of hematuria hypertension and
edema due to volume retention
rhabdomyolysis is also an important
cause of renal type of AR f and patients
with rhabdomyolysis have features like
tea colored urine and muscular pain due
to breakdown of muscle fibers these
patient can also have a history of coma
or recent seizures which may have
initiated rapper molasses allergic
interstitial nephritis is also an
important cause of renal type of AR f
and the patients present with fevers
rash and artha layers these patients can
also have exposure to medicine like
NSAIDs post renal AR F is mainly caused
by obstruction to the urine flow which
can be due to urethral obstruction due
to enlarged prostate in a case of benign
prostatic hyperplasia and these patients
have features like urgency frequency and
hesitancy which are features of benign
prostatic hyperplasia renal calculi can
also obstruct the urethra or bladder and
cause post renal ERF these patients
present with flank pain and hematuria
some words on how we diagnose the type
of a RF blood illiterate profile is very
important which shows a raised serum
urea and creatinine concentration
various type of electrolyte
abnormalities are present like raised
serum potassium arrays serum phosphate
and decreased serum calcium
concentration urine analysis is also
important which shows a low urine volume
in pre Lingle type of a RF urea
concentration of urine is greater as
compared to creatinine and osmolarity of
urine is raised in a renal AR F we can
have red cell casts which are usually
immune mediated real imaging is also an
important modality of Investigation
which involves x-ray abdomen and
ultrasonography which are usually
helpful in cases of post renal a RF to
detect stones or enlarged prostate
renal biopsy helps in pathological
diagnosis of conditions like immune
mediated renal damage the treatment of
acute renal failure is mainly associated
with correction of the fluid and
electrolyte imbalance and also the
treatment of underlying cause please
note that we will not be able to discuss
the treatment of individual topics in
detail due to limitation of time fluid
imbalance is mainly associated with
management of hypervolemia through salt
and water restriction diuretics like
puris amide different type of
electrolyte imbalances can occur most
from any of them are the hyperkalemia
which is managed by a dietary
restriction of potassium
loop diuretics and potassium binding
resins hyper phosphate amia is important
complication of a RF which is managed by
using phosphate binders like aluminum
hydroxide which decrease the absorption
of phosphate through the gut acidosis if
severe can be managed by oral or IV
sodium bicarbonate and also a frequent
monitoring of fluid and electrolyte
levels of the body is required treatment
of the underlying cause since the main
problem in Prejean lar F is less blood
going to the kidneys the most obvious
step will be to improve the blood supply
of the kidneys and fluid replacement is
done depending on the type of fluid lost
blood can be replaced in case of blood
loss crystalloids like sodium saline and
colloids like albumin can be used in
burns & pancreatitis inotropic drugs
like dopamine are also used in case of
heart failure to improve the
contractility of the heart renal AR f
glomerular nephritis is mainly managed
by immunosuppressive drugs and
corticosteroids rhabdomyolysis is
managed by IV fluids in a magnitude of
10 liters per day the treatment of post
renal acute renal failure is simple as
it involves the removal of obstruction
in the form of surgical removal of
prostate known as prostatectomy or stone
removal thank you so much for watching
this video this was all about acute
renal failure like our channel on
youtube for all the upcoming videos and
make sure to LIKE our channel on
facebook for flash cards and upcoming
notifications